et je crois que sous le nom de Jésus tous
le mal si la prostate ne va que chez le médecin
juste pour voir ce qui se passe mais
le remède que j'ai vu mais le coronavirus et avec ça
dans ta tête parce que tu as très peur je sais
que vous dans la tête 24 heures beaucoup
inquiet parce que ce qui s'est passé ne sera pas
viendra un temps où il n'y aura plus
comme tout le monde est bourré la botte plus
ou moins brasilia - l'élection foncière
d'eau de Cologne aujourd'hui les prochains j'étais
mauvais pas à cause de la politique dans le
parents
et les extrêmes de la pauvreté à partir de
alors il veut donner cette avenue
Je te ris un like like alors quelle équipe de
colonie aujourd'hui j'utilise une icône pour être
fiction j'ai fait un peu comme toi
liberté de travail l'autochtone dans
le brésil et d'autres intérêts sourds qu'il a déjà
vivent dans l'air pur du sol afin qu'ils
portera un masque et
et là
C'est le
[Musique]
et là
C'est le
la communauté skar est un monde à part et
ils ont leurs règles et parfois c'est
très compliqué tu as compris
mettre en œuvre une politique dès le premier jour
distanciation sociale si grande
taux d'infection du potager à cause de cela
de cette distance c'est difficile non ?
ce que cela signifie signifie que le
monsieur vous êtes toujours avec mais votre corps
quel organisme crée-t-il déjà
les anticorps de défense immunitaire sont toujours
est-ce que le et elle s'isolent un de plus
un peu
et les offres sont fondamentales mais pour ici
pour la communauté je ne pense pas non plus
c'est juste bien d'avoir le test c'est nous
la personne passe le test elle sait qu'elle est
positif mais alors ce qu'elle va
faire
un câlin parce que c'est dur de s'isoler
que oui parce que parce que les maisons sont
petit et parce que la rue est très tome
serviette de gens qui ne croient pas que
continuer à mener une vie normale
et Aie
[Musique]
g1
ben alors j marques sont le résident de
cité de dieu éducateur populaire nous
nous avons fuba haricots riz sel deux canettes
de saucisse en canette de sucre on a de l'huile
pâtes à la sauce tomate et quoi d'autre
ça y est, ça devrait durer environ 15 jours par mois
en haut à droite avec beaucoup d'efforts de là
piratage familial ok nier je le ferai
laisser ici passer par ici fait un
tarte sensationnelle ok mais c'est tout
influencé la vie des personnes qui
travailleur indépendant, à droite, qui travaillait dans la rue
vendre là-bas
et encore une fois
et puis seulement le mari qui y travaillait
loyer et
et nous nous en sortirons ensemble
c'est aussi
Ana veut supposer qu'il est moche, n'est-ce pas ?
venir avec la chemise dans la bouche
c'est bon, c'est
et Aie
et je pense au Brésil et principalement
à rio de janeiro nous avons un facteur
culturel et historique très fort
la rue n'est pas seulement l'endroit où nous
gagner un revenu où nous allons chercher
notre travail mais quand on regarde
en raison de ce facteur culturel, le prolongement de la rue
de chez nous donc c'est dans la rue aujourd'hui
les gens trouvent dans notre famille
nos amis cette rue que nous
reconnaît notre identité
eh bien ça ne peut pas être comme ça
bon après-midi comment allez-vous nous sommes là
ensemble ok frère dans les exemples de code
la façon dont nous souffrons toujours avec
tout le monde meurt de faim toute l'année
chaque année si pire à cette époque l'anémie
la situation était mauvaise non pas à cause de
de la politique dans le pays alors parlons de pandémie
élévation aux extrêmes de la pauvreté qui est
car je n'ai pas répondu à ton message
pour moi personne n'a jamais appelé
ceci maintenant qu'ils mettent un point d'honneur à
comme toi si l'hypocrisie alors je le ferai
prends-en un nous sommes ici dans une région
dans la cité de dieu appelé à itamar
franco nous allons faire don de ce panier de base
pour une dame nommée angela est une
dame qui en a vraiment besoin et demandera
d'urgence à travers les réseaux sociaux certains
les cas sont très extrêmes, non?
essayez de répondre tout de suite bonjour d'accord
Heureux d'avoir vu votre message ici
oh si heureux d'avoir vu votre message à
le temps j'espère que ça aide ok l'avoir
bonne santé à toi je suis
diabétique droit donc je ne sors pas
aucun seulement à l'intérieur
ah comprendre mais dieu merci le voilà
silencieux
et donc ici donc voyons le
dieu john monk le couteau changeant de look
et sur le chemin avec j'ai fini pour la course
panier il y a des millions d'atténuation de
puis a servi de village de pneu familial qui
vous avez un événement à la fin
c'est difficile de dire l'accentuation du nom
et déjà fait une place à l'époque
et là
salut c'est encore moi hahaha
[Musique]
salut mor salut bonjour ici
le cookie
bonjour, tout ce qu'elle mange j'ai déjà créé
donc depuis que je suis petit, on s'y habitue, non ?
mon nom est valdinei xavier barbosa j'ai
47 ans n'a pas de métier et celui-ci
c'est ma maison et moi avec trois enfants
seul que vais-je faire de ma vie sans
pouvoir travailler ou demander de l'aide
les gens c'est le seul chemin, le droit et la peur
pour sortir dans la rue il reste à l'intérieur
pot de maison pour éloigner la souris
et je suis terrifié par les rats ici tu vois
terrifié ici en ce que la chambre ici la salle de bain
et là
[Musique]
vous ne pouvez pas tout fumer là-bas, vous pouvez voir que
Je n'ai pas d'armoire, tout est foiré
l'autre garçon dort j'ai déjà 10 ans
ans depuis qu'il vit ici maintenant mais
remplir j'ai perdu mes affaires allons y
armoire j'avais gâté non
vivre bien mais alors il n'y avait rien de l'eau
fuir celui-là parce que
besoin là je vais devoir tout atterrir
recommencez, ils me donnent
quelques bouteilles de gel d'alcool me donnent un
javellisant au chlore mais parfois pas
dure longtemps quand je l'ai je nettoie le vase
tous ici participent mais quand ce n'est pas le cas
l'avoir avec elle même quand un
coronavirus et avec cela à l'esprit parce que
ont très peur je suis allé dans la tête 24 heures
à partir de maintenant je ne sais pas comment ça se passe
être je ne sais pas je m'inquiète beaucoup
ce très inquiet et
g1
salut dani est le lait en cours vinaigré et
portails et garde-corps couverts par exemple
Angela Rolinho dans la profession qui donne sera
couplet fort voir plus tard un million de vers
[Musique]
et
c'est au nom de ton fils jésus ton
mot m'assure que seigneur je maintenant
dormir commande la fièvre je donne un ordre à tout le monde
une sorte de nuisance dépouillée c'était et je
Je crois que sous le nom de Jésus tout mal
si amen de la prostate vous recevez recevez
donc je déclare n'aller que chez le médecin
pour voir ce qui se passe mais le
guérir je vois déjà pensé à fermer à 100% si le
Nous faisions
et pour cent comment les gens vont-ils
se nourrir de la foi, comment vont-ils
comprendre que même dans les moments difficiles,
les gens peuvent être fidèles à Dieu parce que mon
système immunitaire selon mon
sur ma conscience me donnera un
la sécurité pour qui a compris le moment est
mauvais mais il y a une force active qui
nous ne pouvons pas arrêter ii
Aujourd'hui je ne porte pas de masque jusqu'à aujourd'hui je
J'ai mis mal à marcher dans la rue alors
conclure celui qui ne m'exigera pas
mettre de la magie parce que c'est la confiance
et c'est aussi
et là
et Aie
et cette chose qui vient a la voix du père
leo merde celui pour qui 300 est
calme désolé alléluia et
la vidéo quand le compresseur
et est allé prolonger si c'est
étirement va mourir va mourir va mourir
mourir mais l'église doit déclarer
la vie je crois en juin en juin et
l'homme de juillet le brésil sera là
complètement libre de ce rocher endormi
série sur la croissance du brésil par van damme mal e
emmener le spécialiste des occupants à la retraite
réseau était j'ai fait le centre-nord que
l'aide d'une rivière d'invitations multiples
dans le tissu un sinon un groupe de vainqueur un
et après tout c'est que ça n'a pas fini
autre chose que la production
zone de réglage fin des minutes
Salut, tout le monde est là, allons-y
Je viens de te voir sortir avec moi ok
et là
le nouveau facebook je fais le
d'abord vous pouvez le voir ici
de 40 funérailles quotidiennes maintenant arrivées
ici à 80 tonnes quoi de neuf
arriver, il viendra un moment où ce ne sera pas le cas
il y en aura plus et peu d'autres sont
bourré
et ici
et puis quand c'était lundi c'était déjà 00
notez qu'il a été discouru il a dit que
Je ressentais beaucoup de douleur de ne pas prendre un as
ses jambes étaient faibles, il pouvait
s'en sortir c'est
et puis maintenant enterrer mon père doit
pouvoir montrer mon portable très triste
et là
[Musique]
et Aie
et là